There are 4 types of analytics:
• Descriptive analytics
• Diagnostic analytics
• Predictive analytics
• Prescriptive analytics
The more complex an analysis
is, the more value it brings.
Descriptive analytics
Descriptive analytics answers the question
of what happened. For instance, a healthcare
provider will learn how many patients were
hospitalized last month; a retailer - the
average weekly sales volume; a manufacturer – a
rate of the products returned for a past month,
etc. Descriptive analytics juggles raw data
from multiple data sources to give valuable
insights into the past. However, these findings
simply signal that something is wrong or right,
without explaining why. For this reason, highly
data-driven companies do not content themselves
with descriptive analytics only, and prefer
combining it with other types of data analytics.
Diagnostic analytics
At this stage,
historical data can be measured against other data
to answer the question of why something happened.
Thanks to diagnostic analytics,
there is a possibility to drill down,
to find out dependencies and to identify
patterns. Companies go for diagnostic analytics,
as it gives in-depth insights into
a particular problem. For example,
in the healthcare industry, analysis of customer
segmentation coupled with several filters applied
such as diagnoses and prescribed medications,
allowed measuring the risk of hospitalization.
Predictive analytics
Predictive analytics tells
what is likely to happen.
It uses the findings of descriptive and diagnostic
analytics to detect tendencies, clusters
and exceptions, and to predict future trends,
which makes it a valuable tool for forecasting.
Despite numerous advantages that predictive
analytics brings, it is essential to understand
that forecasting is just an estimate, the accuracy
of which highly depends on data quality and
stability of the situation, so it requires a
careful treatment and continuous optimization.
Thanks to predictive analytics and the proactive
approach it enables, a telecom company,
for instance, can identify the subscribers
who are most likely to reduce their spend,
and trigger targeted marketing activities to
remediate; a management team can weigh the
risks of investing in their company’s expansion
based on cash flow analysis and forecasting.
Prescriptive analytics
The purpose of prescriptive analytics
is to literally prescribe what action to take to
eliminate a future problem or take full advantage
of a promising trend. This state-of-the-art
type of data analytics requires not only
historical data, but also external information
due to the nature of statistical algorithms.
Besides, prescriptive analytics uses sophisticated
tools and technologies, like machine learning,
business rules and algorithms, which makes
it sophisticated to implement and manage.
That is why, before deciding to
adopt prescriptive analytics,
a company should compare required
efforts vs. an expected added value.
What types of data analytics do companies choose?
For the Global Data and Analytics Survey: Big
Decisions, PwC asked more than 2,000 executives
to choose a category that describes their
company’s decision-making process best. Further,
C-suite was questioned with what type of analytics
they rely on most. The results were the following:
descriptive analytics dominates (58%) in the
“Rarely data-driven decision-making” category;
diagnostic analytics tops the list (34%)
in the “Somewhat data-driven” category,
while it is closely followed by descriptive
(29%) and prescriptive (28%) analytics;
predictive analytics (36%) leads in
the “Highly data-driven” category.
This survey proves that at different
stages of a company’s development,
there appears a need for one
or the other type of analytics.
In fact, the companies that strive for
informed decision-making, find descriptive
analytics insufficient, and add up diagnostics
analytics or even go as far as predictive one.
The same survey reveals another trend.
Executives want decision-making to be faster
and more sophisticated. This means that
more businesses will strive to gradually
enlarge the share of predictive analytics.
Another survey of business intelligence trends
for 2017 carried by BARC proves this hypothesis:
2,800 executives confirmed the growing importance
of predictive analytics and data mining.
In summary, with various types of analytics,
companies are free to choose how deep they need
to dive in data analysis to satisfy their business
needs best. While descriptive and diagnostic
analytics offers a reactive approach, predictive
and prescriptive analytics makes users proactive.
Meanwhile, current trends show that
more and more companies come to
the situation when they need advanced
data analysis, and choose to adopt it.